o trecho do filme tem muito boa tal
bertotti eu sou artista plástica pintas
que lembro escreveu histórias como
lauryn deles que parecem crianças mas
que também são paulo tite e que eu tenho
de fazer por sorte ao serviço dos outros
eu sou voluntária de câncer em hospitais
ea atribuição do zico e companhia
crianças internadas em anshun ferimentos
também a companhia ducci mas acima de
tudo e uma crianças consideradas
diferentes
falta crianças institucionalizadas
retirada das famílias mas também
crianças com autismo 3021 entre outros
foi exatamente por este motivo que eu
fiz uma pós graduação em desenvolvimento
pelas artes possíveis do instituto
superior de psicologia aplicada
especializar e para me tornar mais
eficiente no meu voluntariado as minhas
histórias como a laurinda alves falando
príncipe princesas mas não tem nada a
ver com os princípios e as princesas que
encontraram a minha infância
nessa hora o que acontecia é preciso
casar com o príncipe e viver feliz para
sempre
acontece que a realidade ultrapassa
sempre ficção e minha experiência tem
mostrado que ninguém vive feliz para
sempre e que os contos de fadas não tem
nada a ver com a realidade
muito pelo contrário dos meus livros
os príncipes princesas são inspirados em
que em seis reais e crianças com quem
têm cruzado em situações de grande
fragilidade e pra mim eu cheguei
infinitamente mais mítica qualquer
princípio a qualquer princesas dos
contos de fadas
eu escrevo sobre crianças consideradas
diferentes
crianças que são muitas vezes julgadas
discriminadas e rotuladas pela sociedade
escreve sobre elas e para elas e por
isso hoje que estava muito de contar
três histórias de três crianças que
marcaram a minha vida
três histórias muito simples que
registraram e complexidade de vida que
fizeram também a mim vou dar o meu rumo
as minhas escolhas e hoje vejo tarde
escala numa alegria mas foi numa galeria
lá fora
optei ante está nos hospitais a canseira
dessas crianças e acompanhá-las
a primeira história
eu vou contar e sobralinho eu conhecia
lhes quando enquanto fui voluntária numa
instituição
alice estava institucionalizada com os
dois irmãos clientes
todos estavam completamente sozinhos e
abandonados porque a mãe não tinha
condição para cuidar vent quando um dia
enquanto pintava e conversava com eles
desenhava no horizonte de deus alegrias
e tristezas
a lista o nome que tinha muita
dificuldade entre um ser que tenha
muitos presidentes enquanto começava a
fechar os olhos vi exatamente o padrão
isdb t com muita agressividade na sua
mãe e pôs os olhos dela continuavam
cheias lágrimas e jeans não fosse este
percebeu que inquietava era outro em que
ela vivia todos os seus colegas e
chamarem de burro quando ela me contava
histórias e ficava sem saber o que iria
fazer com enorme tristeza e como devem
calcular ia pensar este criança não tem
nada burra muito pelo contrário
eu penso que é que o que aconteceu ali
eles foi que a vida lhe pregou uma
partida e te concentrou da própria vida
porque existem crianças que infelizmente
nunca são crianças e aquilo que eu
aprendi com alice foi que nós nunca
devemos julgar as pessoas sem
conhecermos porque normalmente o maior
tesouro das pessoas está escondido no
seu interior
e essas pessoas que façam um grande
sofrimento e muitas vezes colocam com
capas por capas e depois nós não
conseguimos contê las naquele lugar
então o que fazemos é burra é tonta e
não se passa e não é na realidade não é
nada disso que acontece até são pessoas
surge muito interessante pessoas fundos
e pessoas que têm um intercâmbio de
mostrar e agradeço muito a eles não ter
dado esta pista é tão valiosa para a
minha vida
a segunda história que vou contar uma
história muito especial para mim porque
é uma história em que eu vou falar sobre
uma criança como caxeta anos e que
chamava maria e que foi minha fiada
eu ia ficar ligada aos seus pais por
circunstâncias adversas que atravessavam
na altura em que desconhecemos
conheceria através da unicer fister
preocupar e maria arranjava pranchas de
surf
lembro perfeitamente em que a conheci
ninguém que chega à casa de wilson era
uma família que vive e vive ainda com
muitas dificuldades e lembra um tirar e
ficarem imediatamente apaixonada por
aquela empresa como já perceberam eu as
crianças peixe não me aquela que eu
dirigisse ao foi amor à primeira vista
e quando eu cheguei olha para aquela
criança que tenha feito um tratamento de
quimioterapia no dia anterior e eu
fiquei impressionada com ela com sua
fragilidade estava sem cabelo devido aos
tratamentos que estava a fazer e ao
mesmo tempo fiquei fascinada com sua
força porque ela não vá atrás dos irmãos
mais velhos com as falhas eu voltar aos
palcos com as irmãs e pensar realmente
domina incrível como é que ela ontem
saibam um tratamento tão duros como
aquele o giba e voltar às paradas com os
irmãos e mary era uma força da natureza
eo pensa que ela era diferente porque
tinha uma capacidade invulgar aceitar a
sua doença mas isso maior diferença eu
penso que era no amor
ela mostra de uma forma diferente uma
vez quando haveria ainda é muito
pequenina estava no ipê roxo lá uma
criança que vinha da guiné e que o
acerto filme exatamente o que a vida em
outra prova da melhor forma
chamava sul mané não tinha ninguém com 1
e todo o carinho que essas crianças
vivem apenas dois auxiliares e das
enfermeiras do hospital
ninguém se aproximar de deus porque eu
tenho o corpo coberto chaves e oposição
em que delas tinham tornava no
perfeitamente impressionante e por isso
os pais também evitavam e não punham os
seus filhos a brincar com ele mas é
minha filha de 105 e até 2030 para
quando viu muito era ainda mais criminal
ele devia ter uns três ou quatro anos e
ganhou imediatamente nem pintado
eu penso que ela sentiu aqui e trilha
pelos seus rins pela sua fragilidade
mas acima de tudo acontecendo como
acontecia acreditou se sentiu atraída
pelas ruas viram nós que chegamos a crer
eu por mim falo mas acredito que quando
somos esquerda quer ser amiga mais ficou
claro que tem mais de mim
os rapazes quer ser amigo do jovem
melhor pó e venha a ser criança e com
este tamanho de calma
eu quero que tudo seja inimigo mais
sozinho mais frágil do minério que sinto
que minha filha estava sozinho no quarto
ela nunca teve a oportunidade de ir à
sua mãe suzana que fosse visitar o
sumaré por que ela tinha consciência que
aquela criança não tinha lá a mendel
poder cuidar eu agradeço muito ao iria
porque ela me ensinou
nós não vê preocupação com os outros ao
ponto não esquecermos de nós próprios
agora é trabalhar para fotografia da
minha filha leis texto essa lote mas
alguma vez uma criança cris saudável o
amor que fica preso em 14 em dirigir
aqui e veja a história agora que eu vou
contar sobre o antônio foi uma criança
que eu conheci num dia em que fui
visitar a maioria ao hospital porque ela
encontrava se já numa fase terminar e e
quando elas a linha esperam dos pais
agora vamos entrar com os seus filhos
estava a mãe nova com seu filho ao colo
e perguntou como é que eu chamava e é
levíssimo antônio e em seguida talvez
porque conhecia também estivesse à
procura de uma resposta para mim própria
perguntado se tinha fé ao que ela
respondeu eu tinha mas olha o que eu
tenho uma cola com certeza que existem
autores dizem que é preciso realmente
muita feia pt fé que um dia as mãos à
cabeça a pensar bem e não tomar gol tudo
o que eu fui perguntar e passaram cada
tentar enviar a instituição eu tinha uma
frase no bolso de alguém tinha oferecido
no dia anterior que dizia foi quanto
mais hostis ao regime que atribui ao
colo e eu fiquei com aquela maior se
essa frase ela continua ficar em
silêncio e eu voltar a meter as mãos à
cabeça o que eu fui fazer
só que depois chamaram na pele entrar lá
dentro com seu filho para fazer o
tratamento e quando ela voltou e aquelas
portas que tanta tristeza arrastam se
abriram
mais bonito que alguém alguma vez já me
fez acreditar que eu às vezes vejo
vistas de moda e tetra nem a claudia
schiffer fez alguma vez um sorriso mais
bonito que aquele era um sorriso mais de
anjo do sul e depois disso sabe há muito
tempo que eu não tinha esperança mas
hoje eu entrei ali dentro cheio de
confiança
passaram se dois anos ea minha afilhada
é importante é tratado no futuro deveria
passar de 2 anos ela entrou nada no
sétimo piso do ipê o em suplemento
lembrando que perguntar pelo antônio foi
ter como enfermeira pergunta lhe servido
antônio e ela disse o que o antônio
também estava internado ali no set e
pizzi também estava em isolamento
efe comeria quando sabia que ela era uma
criança especial certamente iria dar
também uma pista especial disse maria é
madrinha tem nenhuma me crime que está
sozinho e que está doente fez alguma
coisa que ele quer resolver ser alguma
coisa que ele quer dizer que ela tinha
duas pulseiras uma azul é uma cor rosa
claro que ter o azul para a cor da paz e
vip que também tenha escrito nela uma
frase de esperança e premium pela
officer eu fui a correr até a outra
pronta do curvelo lembro-me como se
fosse hoje bater à porta e fui ter com
aquela mãe
perguntado se lembrou de mim no início
não se recordou mas depois quando já
vivia actualmente que tenhamos vivido
dois anos antes em obras ou um abraço
demorado daqueles que nos enchem a alma
página amor sentir ele sim sabe eu não
sei como é que você se chama também não
quer saber é melhor nem se ver porque é
muito melhor assim
obrigada por me trazer as frases nos
dizem que eu mais preciso e aquela mãe
partilhamos o essencial sem nunca termos
teve o nome uma ou outra eu acho que se
o que olha pra mim isso é uma pessoa com
tantas imperfeições
com tantas fragilidades tive a honra eo
privilégio de receber aquela bros
então certamente qualquer pessoa no
mundo tamanho será ainda visita o
antônio mais duas ou três vezes mas com
muita tristeza minha um dia
o instituto português de oncologia e fui
informada que o antónio já não se
encontrava entre a xe mas aprendi uma
vala essencial para a minha vida com ele
e comendo eu aprendi que o amor diz
mesmo ser invisível é muito visível
antônio santa eo pr já o dizia palavras
mais chaves e mais poéticas com todas
essas crianças e sobre todas aquelas que
não contêm nada aprendi que é uma causa
de pessoas que para mim são as pessoas e
jesus é sobre elas que um dos grupos é
sobre elas que escrever sobre elas que
eu pinto e acho que hoje em dia também
sobre elas que eu vivi aqui ficou muito
mais facilidade com muito mais gente
ficou muito mais amor
as minhas histórias visão própria busca
interior fica tão nós eo camping com
elas é que elas ensina é que os dedos
ensinem as crianças aceitar a
respeitaria a viver com a diferença dos
outros porque porque o amor não existem
diferenças
o amor não é diferente as crianças de
frente são sempre rotulado e julgadas
faróis vai também nós passamos a vida a
colocar rótulos dos outros 70 vezes
permitindo de ver o que tá falando de si
mesmo rótulo
o que eu defendo é que nós vemos sempre
fazer tudo para abrir o coração é
especial às pessoas que parecem mais
diferentes porque porque eu acredito que
talvez e sim o amor que lhes foi roubada
ainda possa ser resgatado porque eu
acredito ainda que uma criança que é
amada irá contribuir para o futuro e
para um mundo melhor
penso que cada um de nós pode utilizar
as suas competências e suas ferramentas
pessoais e profissionais em prol das
pessoas e zus na minha opinião nós não
devemos usar a nossa educação é pelo
exemplo nós próprios
vemos o dólar também em prol dos outros
um consultor um médico um engenheiro eu
penso que todas as sessões podem tentar
tirar uma hora de sua semana um minuto
seria e tentar salvar os rios existentes
as crianças existem tantas famílias que
com um abraço 106 pessoas mais felizes
do mundo foi o que aquela mãe me disse
se tenha sentido pelo simples facto de
ter ido visitar uma segunda vez e desta
forma dólares ver através do ar mas eu
penso que é ser simples cidade pode ser
descoberto em qualquer área do
conhecimento
bosta histórias e tente estas crianças
chão pra mim uma enorme fonte de
inspiração
são elas que me permitem que me ajudam a
preencher o branco falta nas minhas
telas e depois é que eu faço é muito
simples eu tenho volts apenas um pouco
do muito que elas ajudam muito obrigado
yang